hello guys and welcome to another video
now i have some news regarding william
defoe's green goblin which if it turns
out to be true it is quite big so let's
get straight into the video so the
rumors going around that apparently sony
wants more of william to froze green
goblin so i would say that they're very
happy with his performance they have
seen that um he's been received very
well of people and want to see more of
william as the green goblin now as we
know in spider-man no way home william
defoe's performance as a green goblin
was probably the best performance in the
movie at least in my opinion i thought
his performance in this film was
actually better than his performance in
the first sam remy spider-man film i
gotta say them removing the iconic green
goblin mask and i'm using william
defoe's facial expressions was probably
one of the best decisions they have made
now coming into this film hearing that
we won't see much of him in his mask i
was actually a bit skeptical but seeing
his performance in the film you know it
was just such a good decision his acting
skills really shined through and i would
love to see more of him but one issue i
can see with this rumor is that his
character arc was completed in no way
home he is no longer the green goblin he
was turned back to good and sent back to
his universe so if you do see more of
the green goblin what would they do with
his character because he's good now are
they just gonna make him bad again that
would kind of just undo the character
development they did in their way home
so the only way i can see this being
possible is they use a variant of the
green goblin over set in a different
time because obviously it can't be set
after no way home so because all of this
i would say take this news with a huge
grain of salt i would say this is more
on the unlikely side but i hope it's
true because i've really really loved
his character no way home and this would
be really fantastic if we can see him
again so let me know what you guys think
in the comment section below do you
think we'll see william defoe's green
goblin again or is this it have we seen
his final performance in no way home let
me know in the comment section below and
also if you enjoyed this video please
like and subscribe and turn
notifications on to show your support
thanks for watching guys